soir au nom de caunes prénom pour
antoine pierre gustave surnom tonio
jolicoeur brad enfants 500 grammes aussi
date de naissance 1er décembre lieu de
naissance dans une clinique taille 30 cm
x 500 g je t'ai dit et sous quoi cheveux
gras ou secs sa classe mais negra le
week end
comme tout le monde quoi les yeux
chassieux lentilles ah non ça fait péter
diop
ça m'arrangerait quand j'aurai ta gueule
mais presbytes pour la tienne en tout
cas à tatouages
oui un seul sur le membre une scène
représentant la chasse à d'anaconda sur
les rives du fleuve amazone sous les
yeux émerveillés du chef raoni
cicatrices intérieur je préfère pas en
parler
autodidacte ou diplômés plomer la muse
ans
prenons un mot simple par exemple
onanisme wipro nombreux secours le
vigoureusement événement l'a autorisée
par qui
kenzo c'est un travailleur immigré mais
il bosse bien tu dors à poils à plume
aussi de temps en temps ça va prendre un
animal ta davis ouais 3 dans le fémur
mauvaise chute
tu prend combien de cuite par semaine
sur la préfecture où sont les
organisateurs premier flirt
c'était en vacances sentait bon le sable
chaud s'appelait thierry fréquences
hebdomadaires des rapports sexuels le
samedi soir vers 22h30 au moment de
double jeu c'est plus facile depuis que
tu es vedette a bien sûr par contre j'en
profite pas honteusement comme certains
confrères ppda masure chapier gillot
pétré
sevran les nuls sauf farrugia thierry
roland non non pas tiré les expériences
homosexuelles
en dehors de ce premier flirt avec
thierry n'ont jamais c'est pas faute de
propositions tués combien par mois dans
les cent mille temps fait quoi
j'investis dans les médias d'avenir la
truffe l'a5 était prêt à tout pour y
arriver
arrivé sans être parvenu ça sera
j'espère mon épitaphe lui pour être sûr
de ne rien rater le lino lardy tube
abonnez vous il mettait un peu de bleu